[Musica]
signori e signore l'intelligenza
artificiale non esiste allora questa è
una provocazione che voglio farvi per
farvi pensare al fatto che probabilmente
come vi è stata sempre raccontato come
la potete spedire nel mondo sembra
questa cosa magica questa cosa che si
auto crea che si auto determina in
realtà non è così e cerco di
raccontarvelo attraverso la mia
esperienza di vita e professionale come
sono arrivata a questa conclusione
allora l'uomo sempre voluto superare i
propri limiti dominare gli elementi il
fuoco voler muoversi nel mondo voler
esplorare voler andare sulla luna ci
siamo arrivati ok è l'ultima delle sfide
è proprio quella di comprendere il
proprio intelletto la propria
intelligenza e allora da ex
neuroscienziata che ha voluto
intraprendere questo percorso di sfida
nella comprensione di uno degli organi
più meravigliosi e complessi che abbiamo
si è fatta questa domanda
a un certo punto dopo quasi nove anni di
ricerca sul cervello
ma c'è un paradosso dietro questa
volontà dell'uomo di capire ed il libro
adoro nell'intelligenza che abbiamo
dentro una macchina e cioè come com'è
possibile capire il cervello analizzarlo
scomporlo e ricomporlo usando lo stesso
strumento cioè come possiamo astrarci da
fuori è oggettivamente analizzare
uno strumento che stiamo utilizzando per
fare la stessa cosa
e allora ti porto in un percorso di
analisi di come l'intelligenza umana si
è sviluppata nella storia e come anche
quella artificiale e dei parallelismi
che troveremo insieme allora io la rari
in un libro bellissimo sapiens definisce
l'evoluzione della cognizione umana come
una rivoluzione è questa in effetti è
stata una rivoluzione perché se pensate
che l'intelligenza umana per come la
conosciamo si è sviluppata in un tempo
veramente molto breve rispetto a tutta
l'evoluzione dell'uomo solo negli ultimi
50 mila anni abbiamo sviluppato una
serie di facoltà cognitive che oggi ci
portano essere quello che siamo allora
la prima pietra miliare nello sviluppo
cognitivo e quella dello sviluppo della
corteccia prefrontale che un po quella
che ci differenzia dai nostri cugini
primati che è permesso di osservare il
mondo a selezionarlo attenti ma mente e
risolvere problemi complessi
dopo abbiamo avuto la necessità di
esprimere questi concerti questa
complessità che si era creata nel nostro
cervello abbiamo cominciato a parlare
quindi a esplorare la dimensione un po
più metaforica del nostro pensiero che
doveva essere espressa attraverso il
linguaggio e poi l'abbiamo voluto
scrivere quindi per tramandarlo per
poterlo far insegnare per poter
divulgare nel mondo fino a poi voler
creare delle connessioni tra queste
conoscenze e cominciare a capire ea
rappresentare questi concetti nel nostro
cervello per poi avere la capacità
critica di manipolare riuscirà a creare
una conoscenza collettiva che poi con il
web
la tecnologia sia espansa
incredibilmente invece la storia
dell'evoluzione nell'intelligenza
artificiale non è proprio così linea
sicuramente esponenziale a un certo
punto della sua storia come quella
dell'intelligenza umana ma ha avuto dei
dei problemi allora in realtà
l'intelligenza artificiale o i principi
dell'internet all'intelligenza
artificiale esistono da tanti anni 2950
più o meno con touring che posso la il
suo test limitation game e quindi da lì
sino ha cominciato ad esplorare questa
materia e ci sono stati degli
investimenti però un certo punto siamo
caduti in un'era di dvd cupezza nella
chiamiamo l'inverno dell'intelligenza
artificiale questo perché perché non
c'erano abbastanza dati e quindi non era
possibile generalizzare i modelli di
machine learning attraverso i dati i
dati sono ciò che viene dato il
nutrimento che viene data una macchina
per imparare quindi senza dati non si
riusciva a farli esponenzialmente
crescere quindi si son perse le speranze
l'interesse anche gli investimenti ma
poi è successo a un qualcosa di
incredibile cioè ci si è accorti
a un certo punto che eravamo in
condizioni di avere tanti tanti dati che
sono stati collezionati negli ultimi
direi 50 anni e quindi c'è stato un
esponenziale sviluppo di queste
tecnologie che veramente nel solo negli
ultimi dieci anni sono ciò che voi
conoscete ad oggi e quindi quali sono
gli elementi mary che aiutano a far
sviluppare questa tecnologia sono
principalmente tre i big data quindi
tanti dati tantissimi dati collezionati
ovunque sia da oggetti come il vostro
cellulare che avete sicuramente in tasca
che raccoglie trilioni di dati ogni
giorno su di voi so dove vi muovete
all'internet delle cose quindi le cose
che catturano dati anche loro
un altro elemento è sicuramente il cloud
computing quindi la potenza
computazionale del cloud e adesso stiamo
sviluppando il quantum computing che
ancora più veloce
testamento e questi due elementi hanno
reso possibile lo sviluppo di modelli di
machine learning ed intelligenza
artificiale molto potenti e allora su
questo tema
guardiamo vi faccio un parallelismo tra
come il bambino impara vedere il mondo è
come una macchina potrebbe imparare a
riconoscere le immagini un bambino da
quando nasce ovviamente senza ricevere
nessuna indicazione nessuna regola su
come deve percepire il mondo ci impiega
più o meno sei mesi prima di poter
vedere i contorni colori e le immagini
se invece viene data a un algoritmo di
riconoscimento visivo più un poco più di
un milione di immagini per per essere
per imparare a riconoscerle questo
algoritmo impiega circa due tre giorni
per poter riconoscere un immagine
esattamente come un uomo quindi da sei
mesi che un bambino impiega per creare
delle connessioni nella sua corteccia
occipitale poter vedere il mondo a tre
giorni di un algoritmo questa cosa
spaventa a qualcuno e allora uno degli
esponenti più importanti
a mio avviso di questa disciplina andrew
g che ha lavorato in google e del
fondatore di cloudera dice che qualsiasi
cosa che può essere processata dal
pensiero umano in meno di un secondo
probabilmente può essere automatizzata
allora guardiamo quindi le conquiste di
questa disciplina nella storia il primo
caso l'algoritmo di ibm deep blue ha
battuto il campione mondiale mai
imbattuto nella storia kasparov nel
gioco degli scacchi che è uno dei giochi
più complessi di problem solving che noi
conosciamo
qualche anno dopo nel 2016
google col su alfa go sfida il campione
mondiale di alfa che ha un gioco
possiamo immaginare come il gioco degli
scacchi al cubo per cui le combinazioni
di questo gioco le possibili
combinazioni sono più grandi di tutte le
parti
l gli atomi dell'universo è un giocatore
di go impiega circa 10 anni per
padroneggiare questo gioco ecco questo
ritmo nel giro di tre giorni
osservando le partite giocate dall'uomo
e poi giocando contro se stesso è
riuscito a battere questo campione
mondiale e ricorderete probabilmente la
stampa qui questo giocatore cinese era
assolutamente basito non riusciva a
capire come fosse possibile qualche anno
dopo con microsoft nel 2016
siamo arrivati alla la possibilità di
riconoscere le immagini e ad arrivare
alla parità con l'uomo nel
riconoscimento di immagini vi faccio un
esempio per me eticamente molto bello
nella diagnosi del cancro
se un medico a un'accuratezza più o meno
del 90 95 per cento nel riconoscimento
di cellule tumorali
grazie all'aiuto di un algoritmo di
riconoscimento visivo che ovviamente ha
imparato ed ha osservato tantissimi
vetrini di cellule cancerogene
ecco la combinazione delle due insieme
delle due conoscenza delle tue abilità
porta un'accuratezza del 99 per cento
interessante che l'uomo comunque più
bravo ad individuare i falsi positivi
mentre la macchina è più brava di
identificare delle piccole differenze
percettive dell'immagine un pochino più
avanti siamo arrivati alla possibilità
di comprendere il linguaggio quindi
tutti i vostri device boys come alex
google cortana sono sicuramente un
esperimento interessante che tutti noi
stiamo utilizzando un'altra grossa
conquista nel 2017 nel 2017 con
microsoft sempre si è fatto un
esperimento si son dati 500 articoli di
wikipedia a una macchina e hanno umano è
una serie di umani anzi e gli si è fatto
un testo usando la stella un test
standardizzato della university of
stanford e gli son si son fatte delle
domande
la macchina è l'uomo hanno risposto
esattamente nello stesso modo e infine
la capacità di traduzione simultanea in
15 lingue del cinese che è una delle
lingue più difficili da imparare i
bambini cinesi imparano a parlare
completamente dopo circa dieci anni
al contrario dei bambini occidentali che
ci mettono 5 intorno ai 5 anni
ma allora che cosa è veramente che ci
differenzia nella macchina perché ho
introdotto l'argomento dicendo che non
esiste l'intelligenza artificiale non
esiste nella misura in cui la vogliamo
pensare come un sistema che possa
analizzare dei problemi complessi allora
facciamo il paragone con la scala
causale di giuda che ha scritto un libro
bellissimo chiamato the book of light
che analizza nella il modo in cui
l'essere umano impara e lo paralizza
verso la macchina allora
immaginate un bambino che impara il
mondo e sta scalando questa scala prima
di tutto comincerà ad associare degli
elementi se faccio a succede b come ha
influenza b dopodiché si comincia ad
associare sempre di più degli elementi
si comincia anche ad esperire lì nel
mondo e quindi si agisce nel mondo e
questo è il pensiero un po più fattuale
no un pensiero un pochino più complicato
si riesce a capire come il nostro corpo
il nostro essere nel mondo possa
produrre degli effetti e come questi
effetti si possano espandere fino ad
arrivare al pensiero creativo intuitivo
al pensiero causale la causa e l'effetto
sono molto diversi tra la correlazione
tra due elementi mi faccio un esempio
molto semplice se uno osservasse
semplicemente due fenomeni per 365
giorni l'anno
il sorgere del sole e il canto
ogni giorno questi due eventi accadono
nello stesso momento col pensiero cordì
associazione puramente di associazione
noi potremmo dire che il sole sorge
perché il gallo canta ma noi sappiamo
che non è così
non vi sto a parlare del sistema solare
quindi questi sono problemi molto
complessi attraverso i quali noi
cerchiamo di spiegare il mondo che è
pieno di incongruenze non è sempre così
lineare e quindi le macchine prenderanno
il sopravvento sull'uomo sarà possibile
che una macchina possa capire cosa sto
pensando cosa sto provando le mie
emozioni
ecco io penso di no penso che noi
abbiamo una responsabilità molto grossa
cioè quella di non dimenticarci la
complessità del nostro pensiero e come
questo debba essere utilizzato grazie
all'intelligenza artificiale che
dovrebbe semplificare dei processi
complessi per noi ad affrontare il mondo
e quindi mi piace parlare della della
responsabilità etica cioè dietro ogni
algoritmo e ogni scelta di applicazione
dell'intelligenza artificiale cioè la
capacità cognitiva dell'uomo il pensiero
critico e quindi un uomo una donna che
devono prendere delle decisioni etiche e
il risolvere dei problemi allora
ritornando a questo la mia storia
se io solo avessi avuto la possibilità
quando ho iniziato a studiare
neuroscienze di capire dove velocemente
dove avessi potuto impiegare le mie
competenze volendo lasciare la ricerca e
avesse avuto un aiuto dall'alto sarebbe
sarebbe stato fantastico non ci avrei
messo tre anni invece
ci ho messo abbastanza per capirlo e mi
è capitata questa cosa meravigliosa
un progetto che ho fatto l'anno scorso
con la scuola di business del
politecnico di milano che si è fatta
questa domanda che ruolo ha oggi
l'università cioè i contenuti li
possiamo trovare ovunque
possiamo da soli accedere a tantissimo a
conoscenza e allora quale è di nuovo il
ruolo dell'università è quello di forse
selezionare questa complessità
il paradosso della scelta oddio dove
devo andare cosa devo cercare e quindi
abbiamo costruito una piattaforma di
continuous learning in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale aiuta l'uomo
a imparare meglio filtra questa
complessità e restituisce una
raccomandazione di contenuti che è stata
disegnata sul gap di competenza di ogni
individuo
quindi ognuno ogni singolo per l'utente
di questa piattaforma avrà dei contenuti
raccomandati basati su ciò che lui deve
colmare in termini di competenza
rispetto a degli obiettivi professionali
e quindi questo è come il march il link
quindi la macchina che impara l'utente
aiuta l'utente a imparare se stesso e
quindi concludo con uno dei miei
preferiti
charles darwin che dice che l'essere che
sopravvive non è quello più forte o non
è quello più intelligente ma è quello
che si sa adattare meglio al mondo e
quindi secondo me un intelligenza
artificiale deve essere vista come uno
strumento potenziante della nostra
intelligenza non possiamo ritrarci dalla
responsabilità di prendere delle
decisioni e di risolvere dei problemi
complessi con il nostro stesso
intelletto ma l'intelligenza artificiale
deve essere quello strumento che
facilita questo percorso che ci fa fare
ancora più domande sensate e che possa
risolvere dei problemi eticamente giusti
e quindi ribadisco la responsabilità che
abbiamo nel costruire questi strumenti
da anche nel fruirli per rendere il
mondo migliore
[Applauso]